SPEAKER: Hi.
I'm Nikhil, and
I'm going to talk
about Kubemci, a new
command line tool
to manage multicluster
ingresses.
I'm going to talk about what
it does, why is it useful,
and how it works.
But before I get
started, I do want
to point out that Kubemci is not
an official supported product.
It's an exploration.
We want people to try it
out and see if it's useful.
Secondly, as I
talk about Kubemci,
I'm going to assume knowledge
about Kubernetes and Kubernetes
Ingress.
If you've used Kubernetes
Ingress with Google Cloud Load
Balancer to create
L7 load balancers,
you can now use
Kubemci to do the same
for multiple
Kubernetes clusters.
Doesn't that sound awesome?
Let's see how it works.
Our top use cases for Kubemci
are low latency and high
availability.
Let's look at this
diagram on the right.
We have two clusters, cluster
1 in GCP zone US Central 1-A
and cluster 2 in GCP zone
Europe West [INAUDIBLE]..
Service [INAUDIBLE] exists
in both these clusters.
Now, if user Alice
from California
wants to need
service [INAUDIBLE],,
we want Google Cloud Load
Balancer to send that request
to cluster 1.
Similarly, if user Bob from
Berlin sends the same request,
we want that request
to go to cluster 2.
This ensures low latency.
If cluster 2 goes
down, we still want
user Bob to be able to
read service [INAUDIBLE]..
In that case, Google
Cloud Load Balancer
should send that
request to cluster 1.
That ensures high availability.
Now, how Kubemci works is it
has a Kubemci Create command,
where you can give it a
name, your Kubernetes Ingress
definition as ingress.yaml
and a list of clusters
in clusters.yaml.
If you run this command,
Kubemci creates the ingress
in all the clusters, in
this case in both cluster
1 and cluster 2, and then
configures Google Cloud Load
Balancer to send the
traffic appropriately.
To parse the list
of clusters, you
can give your
existing kubeconfig.
Or in future, we want to
integrate with Kubernetes
Cluster Registry.
While this is a
high-level overview,
you can also take
a look at the code.
It's open sourced.
You can go to GitHub, and
you'll see all the code there.
You can try it out and start
contributing to the code
as well.
But let's take a look at a demo.
For this demo, I have
two clusters, one in US
and one in Europe.
I have my zpkubeconfig
file, which has information
about both these clusters.
So this is the
kubeconfig file that I'm
going to use with Kubemci.
I'm using a zone printer
app for this example.
What the app does is
it prints the GCP zone
that it is running in.
I've created my zone
printer app in US cluster.
And now I'm going to create the
same app in my Europe cluster
so that the same
app exists in both.
Once we have this
setup ready, I am now
ready to use Kubemci to
create my load balancer.
Let's look at
Kubemci Help first.
Kubemci Help prints all
the available commands.
There's Create,
there's Delete, there's
getstatus to get the status
of an existing ingress,
and Help and the
version of the tool.
So let's look deeper
at Kubemci Create.
We'll look at the Help
for Kubemci Create.
This tells me I need
to pass a load balancer
name and some flags.
GCP project is a required flag.
The ingress spec
is a required flag.
And kubeconfig is required.
So let's try it out.
Let's run Kubemci Create.
I'm going to name my load
balancer zoneprinter-lb.
I have an ingress spec,
and I use zpkubeconfig.
It prints that it created the
ingress in both those clusters,
then created health check,
backend service, URL map,
target proxy, forwarding nodes.
It's creating all the
resources required to configure
Google Cloud Load Balancer.
Once it's done, I can
run getstatus command
to see the status
of my load balancer.
To get the status, I
pass the name and the GCP
project it is in.
And it tells me, yes, such
a load balancer exists,
and this is the IP address.
The load balancer is spread
across two clusters, cluster US
West and cluster EU
West, as I want it.
GCLB, Google Cloud
Load Balancer,
takes some time to configure.
Once it's done, we can hit
this IP address to ensure
that it's working as expected.
To do that, let's hit
that IP address from a VM
in my US cluster.
As expected, it returns
that the request
was served from US West 1-A.
Let's do the same for Europe
cluster.
And in this case,
we expect it to be
served from the Europe zone.
It was served from Europe zone.
So this shows that our setup
is working as expected.
This is great.
You should try it out.
And we'd love to
get your feedback.
Positive or not, any
feedback is appreciated.
Thank you.